Bonjour, et bienvenue dans cet épisode où
nous ne parlerons pas de ce mur, ni de ce
mur, et certainement pas de ce mur, mais du
mur d'Hadrien, faisant de cet épisode le
premier consacré à de l'Histoire Antique!
*Aliénor, chapeau pointu sur la tête, souffle
dans un serpentin l'air patibulaire.* (plan
à filmer la semaine pro après avoir récupéré
le matos chez papa)
Nous nous intéresserons pour cela aux raisons
de la construction de ce mur, à l'histoire
de sa mise en place et de son usage, jusqu'à
son abandon tragique. C'est parti.
On a tendance à penser que si on construit
un mur, c'est qu'on ne veut pas de ceux qui
se trouvent derrière. La vérité est plus
complexe.
Dans la 2e moitié du Ier siècle après JC,
le Nord de la Bretagne est globalement pacifié
et on trouve des forts romains assez avancés
dans les terres écossaises, jusque Strathcaro
et Cardean par exemple.
Cependant, dans les années 86-87 ces forts
ne sont plus entretenus, et de nouveaux forts
sont construits un peu plus au sud.
-Retrait des troupes? Attaques barbares?
Que se passe-t-il?
-Sous le règne de Trajan, qui arrive au pouvoir
à partir de 98, tous les forts du nord sont
brûlés.
-Attention, ce ne sont pas les barbares qui
ont brûlé les forts.
-Ça va, met toi à l'aise.
-Merci. Les troupes romaines, en se retirant
plus au Sud, ont brûlé les forts avant de
partir. Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a eu
invasion! On a probablement voulu retirer
des troupes stationnées en Ecosse pour les
envoyer ailleurs où on avait besoin d'elles,
en Dace par exemple. Veni, vedi, vici.
-Quoi qu'il en soit, une nouvelle ligne de
défense se met donc en place en Bretagne,
plus au Sud, le long de la Stanegate. Elle
court d'Ouest en Est, et est composée de
fortins et de tours d'observation.
-Les tours de guet, c'est ESSENTIEL.
-Plus rien ne bouge donc jusque la mort de
Trajan en 117. L'empereur Hadrien, qui arrive
au pouvoir, ne cherche pas à réaliser des
conquêtes à la différence de ses prédécesseurs.
Il lance une politique différente, dont le
but est d'assurer la sécurité et la prospérité
de l'empire, et cela passe par le renforcement
des frontières, le limes.
-Il crée des forts un peu partout le long
du limes, et abandonne même certaines provinces
comme la Mésopotamie, l'Assyrie... Carthago
delenda est.
-Pour cela, il décide de visiter les différentes
provinces de l'empire, et il commence par
la Bretagne en 122. Il est probable qu'en
arrivant sur place, il ait déjà eu en tête
la construction du mur.
Surtout qu'en 118 y'avait eu une grosse insurrection
des brigantes au Nord, et de leurs alliés
du Sud les selgovae et nantovae.
-Du coup si on fout un mur entre les deux,
BAM, plus d'alliance possible. Malin l'Hadrien.
-Mais à quoi servait ce mur exactement?
Si on regarde les premiers plans, il ne doit
pas être très efficace pour la défense
du territoire parce que les premiers fortins
ne peuvent accueillir que 40 hommes chacun.
L'escalade du mur semble facile, et les chemins
de ronde sont trop étroits pour servir de
poste de combat. Pourtant, on ne garde pas
trace de franchissement du mur ni de destruction
de forts par des barbares.
-Oh, c'était plutôt une zone de surveillance.
Si les brigantes avaient voulu le franchir
ils se seraient heurtés au mur à l'aller,
puis aux forts de la Stanegate, et à nouveau
au mur sur le trajet du retour. Quel intérêt,
franchement. De gustibus et coloribus...
-Ouais, puis le mur gêne aussi la circulation
des hommes, et les contacts entre les différents
peuples. Les brigantes, au IIe siècle, ne
sont pas romanisés du coup.
De plus le mur devient une zone d'échange.
Il est parcouru de portes, que certains négociants
sont autorisés à franchir certains jours
pour aller faire commerce au Nord.
-Moi j'dis que c'était aussi pour occuper
les soldats, hein. Parce que franchement,
vous êtes déjà allés dans le nord de l'Angleterre?
Y'avait même pas de whisky pour passer le
temps à l'époque, alors autant construire
des murets.
-C'est sûr, ça a permis de donner un sentiment
d'importance aux soldats. «Le grand Mur
d'Hadrien, symbole de la puissance romaine,
et c'est ma légion qui participe à la construction!»
Même les pécores qui vivaient au Sud étaient
flattés qu'on leur construise un si beau
bâtiment, aussi loin de Rome.
-Imaginez un peu: le Nord de l'Angleterre,
un paysage totalement sauvage, et tout à
coup BAM: un mur monumental apparaît, alors
que les constructions en pierre étaient rares
dans le coin. Ça en jette.
-Panem et circensem.
-Donc pour résumer: le mur est grand, le
mur est beau, le mur occupe les soldats, sécurise
la frontière et permet de contrôler les
échanges commerciaux.
Maintenant, c'est quand même un sacré chantier:
comment est-il construit?
La construction du mur est confiée au gouverneur
A. Platorius Nepos, même s'il semblerait
que ce soit Hadrien lui-même qui en ait dessiné
les premiers plans. Ce sont des soldats qui
l'ont construit, puisque trois légions ont
été réquisitionnées: la IIe Augusta,
la VIe Victrix et la XXe Valeria Victrix,
soit environ 10 000 soldats.
-Dis, donc, ils étaient LEGION!
Le lieu choisi est la ligne entre la Solway
Firth, à l'Ouest, et la Tyne à l'Est, ce
qui correspond à la partie la plus resserrée
de la Grande Bretagne. En plus c'est une zone
très proche de la Stanegate, qui est un peu
plus au Sud, et où le terrain est très favorable
puisqu'il y a parfois déjà des élévations
de terrain naturelles qui renforcent les défenses
du mur.
On commence par construire des fondations
de 3m de large, et quelques tours de guet
et forts. On devine que la construction a
été faite dans cet ordre, parce que le mur
ne fait finalement que 2,4m de large, alors
que les fondations et certains bâtiments
en font 3: il semblerait y avoir eu un petit
changement de plan. Il mesurait aussi 4 à
5m de haut.
-Par contre à l'Ouest ils l'ont d'abord construit
en mottes de tourbe, puisqu'à l'époque on
s'en servait pas encore pour faire du whisky
fumé. Ils ont fait des mottes de 3m50 précédées
d'un fossé, et ensuite seulement ils les
ont remplacées par de la pierre.
-On a retrouvé les vestiges d'une quarantaine
de camps provisoires, dans lesquels les soldats
étaient logés le temps de la construction.
Ensuite, tous les mille pas sont construits
des petits forts pouvant accueillir 25 à
50 hommes: les milecastles.
-Appelés ainsi puisqu'ils sont espacés d'un
mille romain, en toute logique. Entre chaque
milecastle on a aussi construit deux tours
de guet, qui pouvaient accueillir une douzaine
d'hommes. Si vis pacem, para bellum.
-Les bâtisseurs du mur ont d'ailleurs tellement
bien respecté le plan initial d'un milecastle
tous les milles que l'un d'eux donnait...
Sur un précipice, ce qui est fort pratique,
vous en conviendrez.
Chaque milecastle disposait d'une porte au
Nord et au Sud, ce qui montre bien que le
mur était un lieu de passage et non un espace
fermé. Par exemple, voici ici le milecastle
de Cawfields. On observe des différences
architecturales entre ces milecastles, malgré
les plans initiaux, ce qui laisse à penser
que chaque légion avait son style.
Ensuite, on a également construit des forts,
beaucoup plus grands, qui pouvaient accueillir
environ 500 hommes. Dans ces constructions
on trouvait le QG, appelé principia, une
chapelle aux enseignes où chaque légion
pouvait entreposer ses insignes et son aigle,
une salle de réunion, la résidence du commandant,
quelques appartements privés... Les troupes,
elles logeaient dans des casernes partagées.
Il existait aussi certains services, comme
des hôpitaux, ateliers, écuries, entrepôts...
Bon nombre de ces forts ont laissé des vestiges
de nos jours, comme le fort de Chester dont
on a vu le plan, celui de Househeads dont
vous avez pu voir quelques photos, ou encore
celui d'Arbeia qui a été en partie reconstitué.
La construction de ces forts a duré jusqu'à
la fin du règne d'Hadrien.
-A un kilomètre au Sud du Mur, on a aussi
creusé un fossé, que les premiers archéologues
ont appelé vallum alors que ça signifie
rempart. Animus Meminisse Horret.
-Si elle continue avec ses citations latines,
je chante en ancien français.
-Ce vallum était large de 6m, profond de
3, et on ne pouvait le franchir qu'au niveau
des forts et des milecastles par un pont et
parfois même une porte. Il semble donc qu'il
avait pour but de contrôler l'accès au Mur
par le Sud, mais à l'encontre de qui? Mystère.
Au Nord du Mur, on a aussi construit de nouveaux
forts entre 122 et 128.
Une fois le mur terminé, les légions qui
ont participé à sa construction sont renvoyées
dans le Sud et ce sont des troupes auxiliaires
qui en assurent la garde, les corvées, l'entretien,
etc.
-Dans l'armée romaine, les troupes auxiliaires
sont des corps issus de peuples étrangers
à Rome, qui font partie de l'empire mais
ne sont pas citoyens romains, n'exagérons
rien. Abyssus abyssum invocat.
-Car vous m'estes sans mercy, et sans pitié
duuuure...
- Parmi ces troupes on trouvait des personnes
venues d'Afrique, d'Assyrie, de Hongrie, de
Bulgarie, de Gaule, d'Espagne et d'Allemagne.
On a une idée des origines des troupes auxiliaires
grâce aux objets retrouvés près du mur,
qui prouvent aussi que le commerce à travers
l'Empire fonctionnait pas mal, même aussi
loin dans le Nord.
En terme d'aménagement, on trouvait un peu
de tout au Mur: comme il était traversé
par trois rivières, on trouvait à l'extérieur
de certains forts des thermes, mais aussi
des boutiques, des tavernes et des bordels.
-Elle est belle, la légion romaine.
-Des auxiliaires! Les soldats n'ont pas
le droit de se marier avant la fin de leur
carrière, qui dure 25 ans tout de même.
Beaucoup se trouvent donc une femme sur place,
qui vit près du fort. Seules les femmes d'officiers
avaient le droit de les rejoindre. Agnosco
veteris...
-Souvent, des villages se développaient près
des forts, dans lesquels on trouvait donc
les familles des soldats mais aussi toutes
les activités qu'on ne pouvait pas placer
dans les forts: des ateliers, boutiques
d'artisans, etc.
On trouve bien sûr aussi des lieux de culte,
notamment consacrés à Mithra, un dieu particulièrement
honoré dans l'armée, mais aussi à des divinités
locales.
En 1973, des archéologues ont découvert
plus de 900 tablettes de bois appelées tablettes
de Vindolanda du nom de la garnison où on
les a trouvées. Elles sont rédigées en
latin, et constituent un témoignage très
précieux de la vie au Mur: on y trouve
des courriers à destination des soldats vivant
au mur ou envoyées par ceux-ci, et donc les
noms des habitants de Vindolanda, ce qu'ils
mangent, ce qu'ils font de leurs journées...
L'empereur Antonin succède à Hadrien en
138 et décide immédiatement d'une nouvelle
politique: il veut abandonner le mur pour
en construire un plus au Nord.
-Aller plus hauuut!
-Vers 142 il remporte une victoire contre
les peuples du Nord et à partir de là il
réaménage les forts abandonnés par le passé,
fait construire de nouveaux avant-postes...
Et un nouveau mur, de 40 milles romains, construit
par les mêmes légions que pour le mur d'Hadrien.
Il s'agit d'un mur de 3m de haut, avec un
chemin de ronde protégé par un parapet en
bois au sommet, et ponctué de fortins.
-Une nouvelle brique dans le mur, quoi.
-Il était aussi précédé d'un fossé de
13m de large, car on n'est jamais trop prudent.
Encore une fois, ce sont des troupes auxiliaires
qui le gardent. Durant l'époque du mur d'Antonin,
le mur d'Hadrien n'est pas abandonné mais
les portes des milecastles sont démontées
pour faciliter la circulation des hommes et
des marchandises et le vallum est comblé
à certains endroits.
-Après ça, c'est un peu le yoyo: en 157
les troupes abandonnent le mur d'Antonin et
démantèlent les forts pour se replier vers
le mur d'Hadrien, puis en 161 elles repartent
au Nord, et vers 164 elles redescendent...
-Oui, bon, ça s'en va et ça revient, il
y avait sûrement une stratégie très perfectionnée
derrière tout ça.
-Il est possible que la guerre contre les
Parthes ait contraint à une redistribution
des troupes, et donc qu'il y ait eu moins
d'hommes au Mur. Le mur d'Antonin est donc
définitivement abandonné mais pas celui
d'Hadrien: en 175 on y envoie 175 000 cavaliers
sarmates, ceux qu'on voit dans ce film là,
mais sans le roi Arthur, c'est ballot.
-Oooh ça sent le roussi, ça. Il n'y a pas
beaucoup de cavaliers dans l'armée romaine,
alors pour qu'on en envoie autant...
-Ben c'est que ça bastonne sévère contre
les barbares. Et ça continue jusqu'à la
fin du IIIe siècle où apparaissent les pictes,
que vous pouvez retrouver dans cette vidéo
de qualité. Eux n'ont pas de scrupules à
attaquer le mur, tranquille.
A partir du Ve siècle, le mur décline, tout
comme l'empire romain. Les légions sont rappelées
plus près de Rome pour assurer sa défense
et les pauvres pécores qui vivent loin de
l'Italie sont un peu délaissés. On estime
à 410 la fin de l'occupation romaine de la
Bretagne.
Cependant, tous les soldats auxiliaires ne
retournent pas à Rome. Certains continuent
d'occuper le mur jusqu'à une période avancée
du Ve siècle, même si plus aucun ordre ne
vient de Rome, et d'autres délaissent leur
poste et s'installent dans la région en tant
que paysans.
-Ouais, parce qu'il y avait pas beaucoup d'autres
perspectives de carrière dans le coin.
-Les déserteurs! Pas étonnant que Rome
ait chuté.
-Du coup, le mur abandonné, ses pierres commencent
à être réutilisées pour d'autres constructions,
comme ce fut le cas de beaucoup de monuments
antiques. On en retrouve certaines dans les
fondations de l'abbaye de Hexham, par exemple.
-Je sais que c'est qu'un monument matériel,
mais ça me rend quand même triste.
-Si ça peut te rassurer, aujourd'hui une
bonne partie du mur existe encore, surtout
sa partie centrale, et il a été inscrit
au patrimoine de l'UNESCO en 1987. On peut
encore se promener le long du mur, visiter
les ruines de certains forts ou milecastles,
et apprécier certaines particularités du
Mur comme ses falaises ou encore cet arbre
ayant poussé dans un creux entre deux collines,
et qu'on retrouve dans le film Robin des Bois.
Celui avec Kevin Costner.
Vu du ciel, le mur a laissé ses marques dans
le paysage, et on peut observer les traces
laissées par le mur même là où il n'existe
plus, par les anciens camps romains, et même
par le vallum, le fossé qui se trouvait jusqu'au
Sud. Ouais, je voulais terminer sur de belles
images, parce que... ce sont de belles images.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, on
se retrouve le mois prochain, à peu près,
comme d'hab, je vous laisse donc avec les
petits symboles qui vont bien et une chanson
qui n'a rien à voir
avec
le mur parce qu'à part Pink Floyd je manquais
un peu d'idées. A bientôt!